hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll today we have
a special treat Scott Derrickson is an
accomplished movie director writer and
producer responsible for films such as
The Exorcism of Emily Rose sinister and
most recently the Marvel movie dr.
strange Scott's also an extremely
thoughtful guy with strong ideas about
the craft of filmmaking at the history
of cinema and the relationship between
movies and other art forms so we have a
wide-ranging conversation which
basically falls into two parts the first
thing we did was we sort of
deconstructed the making of a big
blockbuster superhero movie using Doctor
Strange as an example so we lay out the
whole thing from the initial pitch the
meeting where you talked to the studio
and see if you're on the same wavelength
through pre-production shooting reshoots
and finally post-production
you'll learn for example why the cast
and crew especially Benedict Cumberbatch
thought it was really important to shoot
on location in Nepal and why digital
photography is okay for most shots in a
big movie like this but why you have to
switch to film once you're outside in
the sunshine these are things that as a
theoretical physicist I'm not generally
up on so I really learned a lot from
this conversation then in the second
part we'll talk more broadly about the
idea of cinema and film and what it
means the role of themes and stories in
filmmaking many of Scott's films have
been horror movies and we talk about the
unique role of that particular genre in
evoking a certain kind of human reaction
how that relates to the existence of
evil and everyday human anxieties
whether or not you have supernatural
boogeyman in your movie or not we also
come from different perspectives about
the fundamental nature of reality Scott
as a Christian I am a naturalist and so
we talked about how one's worldview
influences the story one tries to tell
in a movie and Scott says the answer is
a lot he said would be very very
different moviemaker if he suddenly
converted to atheism tomorrow but it's
unlikely to happen we also agreed though
that the world is more interesting with
people coming from different
perspectives so Scott says he doesn't
want me to convert to his religious
viewpoint only afterward that I realized
that maybe this means I'm going to be
condemned to eat
damnation happily I must assure about
that and I don't even believe it myself
so I'm not really worried but it's one
of the things that you had to take into
account when you talk about these big
picture issues anyway this was truly a
great conversation I'm sure you're going
to enjoy it
remember that if you're so inclined you
can support mindscape on patreon patreon
comm slash Sean M Carol we love our
supporters thanks so much and whether
you're a patreon Pledger or not thanks
very much for listening
so let's go
[Music]
scott derrickson welcome to the
mindscape podcast so good to be here
thanks now I do want to talk about
big-picture stuff you know themes and
cinema and all these great things I know
that you have lots of opinions on but I
thought let's set the stage and get into
it by being a little more down-to-earth
so your you've directed Doctor Strange
yeah big blockbuster Marvel movie when I
see movies like this these days and we
all see them one of the things is at the
end of it the credits are very very long
yes it's a gigantic operation to
Shepherd something like this from start
to finish so why don't you for the
audience who are not necessarily
cinephiles they just explain like what
it's like from you know the initial
pitch for the idea to opening night I
mean for a movie that size from the
original pitch to opening night is
probably usually about two years you
know for a movie of that size and the
script process goes on for a good you
know six to nine months but before hard
what they call hard prep hard
pre-production begins so that there's
always that you know six to nine month
period where you're getting the scripts
written rewritten putting it in shape
where you're breaking it down and
getting it ready to shoot and then that
process for a movie this size always
continues through prep and through
production you never stop rewriting you
never stop rewriting and by the way
that's that's there are plenty of
directors who worked that way anyway you
know Stanley Kubrick I'm reading the
book but about him and his relationship
with arthur c clarke and and he was
rewriting 2001 all the way through posts
i mean he was just rewriting my
impression is his relationship with all
of the authors he adapted was tetchy
well yes they give especially given the
fact that he said only bad in movies and
make only bad books and make good movies
hey it may have been a reason why the
relationship was Tut was always touchy
but it was certainly in this I highly
recommend that book by the way that the
relationship that the two of them had
is so fascinating in the book is really
dense really well researched and I know
a lot about that movie and I didn't know
anything in that book but anyway so back
to your question then you've got three
major phases of filmmaking which is
pre-production I think the longest and
most important phase because that's when
you're really designing everything that
will become the physical reality of it
like I don't want to pass too quickly
over the pitch yeah sure right like you
know did I mean obviously Doctor Strange
is a pre-existing ideas so it's a
different kind of thing there's there's
all sorts of different ways that movie
can come about but did you have an angle
on the movie and then go to Marvel or
did they come to you and say hey do you
want to think about this that's a good
question they did what they did is they
they had a pool of directors that in
their minds were possibilities and it
was a large pool I mean dozens of
directors that they liked and and at
this point Marvel was beginning its
really big expansion which has taken
taking place in just the last few years
and and and they had approached me years
ago about four and I just told them I
wouldn't know how to make the figure oh
yeah not my superhero just that you know
and I don't think there's any superhero
that I would have felt personally drawn
to except for Doctor Strange so when I
heard they were making Doctor Strange I
felt immediately like this is this is
something I could definitely do and the
way the process worked was they brought
me in along with the gun dozens of other
directors and they had a short document
signed an NDA and on disclosure
agreement and you read this document and
I was very impressed with a document
because the things that were in there
were essentially what they felt should
and shouldn't be a dr. strange movie it
was very basic but it but it lined up
perfectly with mine which was you know
they really liked the the the deep ideas
and the philosophical overtones of the
Doctor Strange comics they date there
were aspects of the Lovecraftian
monsters that they weren't interested in
at least in a in an early film and I was
I felt like they understood the
character this lonely isolated
character who is different than other
superheroes because of his relationship
to other dimensions not in not in the
scientific sense but in the Marvel comic
universe sense and and that they were
looking for a way to open up you know
the the MCU the Marvel comic universe
the Marvel Cinematic Universe to a
multiverse you know where that were
you're actually dealing literally with
other dimensions unlike Oz guard which
is out there in our own unity somewhere
somewhere you can fly there if you got a
view got a means to get there I was
actually part of the science advising
for Thor oh yeah which was a huge aspect
of that movie right and I think and I
think because they did that so well in
in that movie I think that they
recognized that when it came to Doctor
Strange it was okay to let magic be
magic exactly I think that that part of
it was Thor despite being a God in some
sense like we're gonna portray him as
pretty grounded we think he's a God
because he's super powerful but it has
to make sense and you know almost
intentionally leaving the magic thing
for later in the series and that's where
you could do it right because if be as
much as I love and respect science I
don't think that an approach of trying
to scientifically validate the mysticism
of Doctor Strange would be interesting I
mean would feel like a disrespect to the
comics yeah and so so in fact that
that's not where they were coming from
was was great so I immediately thought I
think I'm the right guy to do this movie
I mean I felt a real deep conviction
about it and I decided that I would put
everything I could into getting that job
and I I just decided that I was going to
work harder to try to get that job than
anything I had ever done before in terms
of efforts to get hired for things
this is obnoxious but I've said it
publicly before I spent forty two
thousand dollars of my own money on a
presentation Wow
which was the eighth of eight meetings
that I made it back didn't you well not
only did I make it back but one of the
first things when they hired me is they
said we have to buy that profession
because we need to own all that material
so so that was immediately
my firt even before I had a directing
deal I got all that money back but it
was it was for me it was it was coming
from a very personal place it wasn't so
much that I I mean I was excited to make
a Marvel movie but I've never been
somebody who's been enamored by
big-budget filmmaking as opposed to
small budget filmmaking you know they
they they they have they all have their
pros and cons as an artist to work on
they all have their pros and cons as
films to watch but in this case I just
felt like this is a movie that I think I
could do better than maybe anyone else
like I'm a right I'm the right fit for
this and that became my focus was to
show them why I was the right fit yeah
yeah and so you did that and they picked
you they did and so then you can start
this wonderful process that you started
and so pre-production I mean there was
there's scripts being written and I
presume there's a certain Hollywood
thing right there's some people who get
credit for the script but there's
probably more voices that came in to
actually yeah in this case there were
you know the two credited writers were
John Speights who wrote the first draft
who's a mutual friend of you know him
and and and he was one that that we
picked you know based on his original
screenplay for Prometheus which was
called I think alien engineers was
brilliant you know that screenplay was
so good and I would just had been a fan
of his original script for passengers
was brilliant and and we hired him so he
did the first draft and then myself and
cargo my writing partner who's here
sitting next to me I'm just listening in
just like he's a car girl on Twitter
that's that's a here to pump the car his
Twitter feed but yeah we came in and
reroutes for quite a long time I mean we
must have done you know 20 drafts 25
drafts something like that and and then
there were some other writers who came
in and took passes on it to add humor to
you know try fixing some structural
problems that we have
dan harmon did a quick pass on it which
which would there wasn't much that he
wrote that ended up in the script but
his analysis of where we were having
problems in the movie was so spot-on
right so he was he was actually a
critical component in that movie well
you know eventually working I'm
finishing up you know writing a book a
popular book on quantum mechanics and I
always send out my books to be read my
drafts by other people and sometimes
they go like no chapter three needs to
be chapter eight and like of course yeah
I think exactly why and and I that was
you know so that whole process working
with with a budget this size is very
common it's not it's not so common
sometimes if you're working with with a
true auteur director you know they'll
they'll do everything on their own and
it works out and sometimes it doesn't
but I I don't mind the process of
working hand in hand of rewriting other
people's scripts or having my scripts
rewritten as long as the people are
talented and you know meanwhile there's
like a million things going on casting
yeah set design it all happens all at
the same time and are you kind of the
boss or partly the boss of all that um
yeah it's so you know you're the you're
the captain of the ship yeah and so
everything goes through you and and
everybody has to come to you you know
for information about what you're
looking for and you give that
information and there's a tremendous
amount of delegating clearly but you you
ultimately are responsible as being the
only person who's holding it all
together in your in your head
yeah you know and and a big part of that
process becomes helping for me it's to
with on Doctor Strange in particular it
was really two things I mean one of them
was making it really clear to all the
major department heads what the target
of the movie was what it was that we
were going to be making and and for me
it was an emphasis upon this is a
mind-bending mind trip action movie
about a soul personality about one guy
overcoming himself getting passes on I
mean at some point at this point the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is mature
right right you have to look for ways to
distinguish yes and you have to you have
to say this is not this is
unlike these other films and this way we
but we I do like this Sensibility you
know for you know for Marvel it but for
example when it came to performances you
know some Marvel films are more
over-the-top and and and cartoony or
comic-book II if I can use that phrase
and I dr. strange because we were going
to be venturing out into such
fantastical terrain I actually wanted
the performances to be very realistic
right you know so that was part of the
casting process which is you know why we
got such serious actors you know to play
pretty dramatic roles Rachel McAdams and
Tilda Swinton and shoot elegy for and
you know these oscar-winning people and
and of course Benedict and and probably
you know that sensibility was something
that everyone needs to understand you
know so as a director you have to make
certain a certain basic vision of what
the movie is going to be clear to
everybody so that they understand the
sensibility behind it and and I think
that's so helpful and then encourage
them my whole process for sure is
encourage them to bring me better ideas
than mine right you know and and then
they always do you know a lot of
recruiting of actors I mean sometimes
they want the role really badly other
times they're they're hard you get no no
in the case of the major roles for
Doctor Strange I mean we went after
every one of those actors you know for
for specific reasons um benedict was our
first choice we wanted him we and and
that we talked about other possibilities
for a very short time but we Kevin Feige
who you know runs Marvel you really make
the movie with him you know he's he's
not just a studio head he's very hands
on he's really in there with you without
a lot of middlemen and and he and I
quickly agreed that that he was the
right guy and I flew to London
immediately and met with Benedict and
the timing didn't work out because he
was doing Hamlet in London and so then I
had to start looking for other actors
and nothing was I mean I met with
amazing actors but in the end it was
like it's got to be benefits in hand and
Kevin to his credit you know went for
the second time back to Disney and said
we really want Benedict so we need to
move the release date so we moved the
release date from the summer that's a
huge deal it's a huge deal because the
fall is not as lucrative it's just not
and so we we probably could have made
even more money in terms of opening day
and that sort of thing but we wouldn't
have made you know the movie that we
made because it's so centered around
Benedict and at the same time you're
deciding what the sets are going to look
like like I remember I don't know if you
saw this little video you can find on
youtube the Russell brothers did a video
about Infinity Ward they just analyzed
like a little 30-second scene right and
it was where Thor appears with the
guardians of the galaxy and it's a great
scene but it just impresses on you know
someone like me who is not in the
business how much effort goes into those
30 seconds like with the lighting coming
from particularly and the postures of
every actor and which thing you're gonna
do and this is all going in your mind in
this production phase right yeah and you
in the breakdown of all the different
elements that have to go into how to
shoot those particular sets and and that
this is why the pre-production phase is
the most critical phase you know because
you've got to have enough time first of
all to dream it up and and and and then
to to thrash it and and criticize it in
your mind and think about what what
could be better I think one of the main
reasons why so many big blockbuster
movies are not great is because you have
enough money to afford your first idea
and it's good and your first idea is
rarely your best idea and so it takes a
a real conscious discipline to to come
up with these ideas but then to be very
harsh and critical of them and and to
their credit I think it's one of the
things that Marvel does better than
anybody you know they are they they are
not ever impressed with their own work
and so everything is always being
criticized by everybody all the time
which can as the director can become a
little painful at times you know but
it's like being scientist actually ya
know say it's the same same idea which
is you know if you want to get to the
you the best version of something or to
the truth of something or to an ideal of
some kind you know you're not going to
get there without admitting to all your
shortcomings and all your failures and
all the things that actually don't work
and don't quite line up and you know and
it's true of writing as well you know
the phrase that we would always use in
working on Doctor Strange between myself
and Cargill in particularly John
Speights was we're doing a lot of hand
waving in this scene you know and and
the hand waving of we're all pretending
like this works in a way it actually
doesn't work that's literally with his
the sight of each other your hand waving
this yes particularly question yes and
and and it's the same thing and because
so much of filmmaking you know is like I
love the fact that the Academy is the
Academy of Arts and Sciences you know
because there is so much of you know
what you're in service of is art but so
much of the actual making of a movie is
science so much of it is just physical
it's practical it's you know and and
even down to things in the case of
Doctor Strange and this gets still to
your initial question about
communicating with department heads one
of the things that I was adamant about
from the beginning that was probably the
hardest concept to get across to people
was that we were going to have these
incredible fantastical sequences of the
you know mind trip through you know
through multi dimension multiple
dimensions and and New York being turned
into this s rescue puzzle and and and
the people fighting in their astral
forms you know all that but my mantra
was I want the physical materials of
what is on screen the physical material
that that the audience is looking at to
feel tactile and real and like something
they can relate to as opposed to say the
Emperor's you know amorphous lightning
bolt finger lights like we don't have a
reference for anything that looks like
that in our experience you know
lightning is sharper edge than that yeah
you know so it's even Tesla light is is
more defined that so I was always coming
back to that like no amorphous light no
no I don't want to represent magic
as being this I want it to be so for
example when they create the mantras you
know that's very crispy sparkly material
that looks like the sparklers you grew
up playing with and looks like fire and
look you you feel like you have a sense
of what it would feel like to touch that
material right see one of the distance
between this crazy magic stuff and our
human experience to be as short as
possible exactly because I think that
that as soon as it's not a sin if you
try to merge if you try to communicate
magic I felt and I still feel that if
you try to communicate magic with with
physical representations that have no
human context in terms of their tactile
your visual tactile relationship to them
in your own mind then your create you're
using something unrelatable to try to
communicate something unrelated play and
I really feel that the best way to get
the audience to feel a sense of awe is
if you're showing them something
unrelatable but everything that's
actually in the frame has a physical
relate ability to their experience yeah
like that was a bit and that's
everything I'm into just took me you
know like several minutes just to try to
get the concept across to to you and
it's you can see how that's a difficult
thing than to get across to a farm of
you know 50 visual effects operators
well is it the same thing where you're
saying about you know the first idea is
not the best one in this CGI ready age
it's maybe too easy to just make some
amorphous lightening bolts do all the
work exactly right exactly right and and
it was it was a constant struggle to you
know reject things and I think that at
times it was very frustrating for the
visual effects people because they they
they aren't weren't used to that kind of
scrutiny or and and I was pointing them
I was saying you know we were doing
these things that are so fantastical and
no one's done it before and and and
we're were there's no precedent for the
visual thing that we're doing but it
can't it can't look unreal right exactly
yes it was really but but they but but
they they did really get behind it like
they I think that once they once I
managed to communicate that at a deep
enough level something something sort of
kicked in and it was
it was industrial light industrial light
magic and a company called luma and a
couple others you know they that the
head people who were working on the
project for those companies became very
excited at the prospect you know and and
suddenly realized that they were going
to get to create some things that that
were gonna be boundary-pushing for them
right you know and yes and that's a
message across that and that that's what
you want you want them to get excited
that they get to be co-creators that
they get they get to bring I wanted them
to bring me things that superseded my
ideas but I kept kicking them back
because it was like it's not that kind
of magic it's not you know I don't like
it has to feel physically tactile to the
audience they've got to have a some way
of relating to every piece of visual
material they're looking at okay in some
point production starts yeah there you
are
where did where did you start what was
the first thing you did the first thing
we did is Nepal we shot in Kathmandu
Nepal and and we had gone there three
times I think we did an early scout
there before the big earthquake and then
the earthquake occurred and we did a
second Scouts and it was the there was a
real question about safety about working
there because you know if another quake
happened you know and it was it was
there were huge piles of rubble
everywhere and some of the sets that we
had picked were destroyed so it was it
was a but but it was a pretty major
decision and Benedikt to his credit sort
of led the charge and saying that we
have to shoot here now like we have to
like they need it they need they need
that they need to be Nepal to be
represented because tourism you know
it's a third world country and and and
tourism is one of them primary sources
of income and tourism just you know just
vanished after the earthquake and and he
really felt like this is a special place
he had history there he'd been there
when he was younger and he said we have
to shoot here now because it's a it's a
moral good and and you know is it well
we'll find a way to make it all safe and
everybody got behind that it was great
yeah yeah and how long is the actual
shooting take overall with the Marvel
movie shooting days are usually around
88 and
85 days you know which is not much I
mean does it feel rushed yes yeah and
and and but they have their they have
very good reasons for doing it I think
because I think that you know for
example my my first assistant director
who had just come off specter the James
Bond movie that movie was a hundred and
twenty three shooting days you know and
I made Doctor Strange in like 85 and and
but what it does is when you know that
your production time is so compressed it
just makes everybody raise their game
because when you get the reality of the
schedule in front of you and you realize
on these on this week we have to
accomplish all of this ever just where
everyone works harder and and I I think
that there is a lot of truth to it was
Orson Welles who said the absence of
boundaries is the enemy of art and and I
really believe that's true which which
you need I think a measure of pressure
and limitation in order to facilitate
the highest measure of creativity I
think Robert Frost had the famous quote
about you know would he ever write free
verse and he says it's like playing
tennis without a net right it's not fun
anymore right right exactly so so I
think that they that there's a real
method to two marbles approach to that
but they also work with the
understanding that they're all there's
almost certainly going to be a sizable
amount of reshooting well I was gonna
ask so I presume they're doing some
special effects work while you're
shooting there's must be an enormous
amount of effort just to put together
what you've shot on are you shooting
digitally or yeah you know we actually
in Katmandu we shot all of that on film
III I am a big believer in digital
photography it's not just the future
it's it's here it's like what everybody
works on with the exception of a few
authors like Tarantino and Chris Nolan
who can afford you know to shoot all
their their films on on actual film but
I've yet to see still a daylight
exteriors look great on digital I just
think daylight exteriors you know have a
have a quality even the best work that
I've seen still has a quality that
pails so to film and so we do we did I
did was able to convince everybody that
we need to shoot cats during science
question because there's no reason in
principle why I couldn't look as good
it's just two different ways of
recording photons landing on your you
know detector somehow but yeah in it but
but I think I think about film I agree
there's something that that makes it
feel more real it makes it feel more
real and I think that it has to do with
with our experience of the specificities
of sunlight and again it's like cloud
cover if it's a cloud cover day like we
did Digital exteriors on sinister and
thank God there was cloud cover then we
shot those because they look great right
it all looks great that would that that
the differential between you know film
and digital when it comes to you know
cloud cover days is in my opinion
negligible it's not that important but
daylight exteriors when you're dealing
with sunlight on people's faces or
shooting the actual sky itself the
difference is is enormous I mean so
enormous that for me it always pulls me
out of a movie when I'm looking at
digital daylight exteriors they just
they just don't feel real and when you
start with the reshoots are the reshoots
something is planned in presumably to
the schedule and is it mostly because
you say this scene isn't working or we
could do it better what makes you go do
it this time well what what you do is
you put the movie together and and most
of the visual effects are not being done
yet because you want to have the movie
in relatively good shape before you
start building all those visual elements
so the post-production process is when
you build most of the effects so there's
a lot of green screen in that first cut
and and and what you really need to do
is get it together and get it in front
of people quickly you know and if
whether it first it's you know five
people ten people and then you get a
small little in-house crew of you know
fifty strangers to watch it and and you
it you will learn very soon and and and
and and painfully like it or not what
doesn't work you know and what does work
and what doesn't work and you you get a
good idea of okay here's here's what our
problems are and and and that begins the
process
of start you immediately start to plan
okay what are we gonna need to do to be
different to mate to solve some of these
problems now occasionally even a big
movie like Mara a Marvel movie doesn't
need much of that I believe they only
did a few days of reshoots for the
Avengers for the first Avengers that
movie just came in everything worked you
know
that's rare even for a you know a small
independent film you know I mean I we
didn't know reshoots on sinister that we
didn't need them that's rare
you know you know as a three million
dollar movie but on Doctor Strange we
definitely did but we also knew that we
would because we knew that we were
struggling with certain things he you
know still in the screenplay well while
we were making it and the surprising
thing is what does work that you didn't
think would work and what doesn't work
that you assumed would work you know
it's always it's always a lumen a ting I
think I think filmmaking is a bit like
baking you know where if you're a if
you're a chef and especially if you're a
world-class chef you're an expert at
understanding you know if I put these
ingredients together and I put them you
know but you got to do that got to do it
you gotta do that the first time but you
know once and filmmaking is like
creating a recipe for the first time and
you know so many things about house and
work but then it goes into the oven and
what comes out is what's gonna come out
you know and when it comes out it's
gonna come out and surprise you in some
way it might be way better than you
thought it probably will not be as good
as you thought I've had some dishes in
fancy restaurants that clearly should
have been tasted before they came out
yeah so there's a there's a component of
I think you put all the ingredients in
you you make all the hard choices you do
try try to make you in your mind as a
director you've made a perfect film you
visualized everything you know you see
it all but then when the actual thing is
there you you have you have to come to
realize the things that don't work and
then how much time is spent between the
end of the reshoots and opening night uh
we had a very short post production
schedule we did because score yeah
there's
you know because of because of
Benedict's schedule and having moved it
to the fall we still had we had a long
prep which again I think was the most
important thing but we had a short post
and and the result was a kind of crazed
panic because we had to get all those
reshoots done and get the visual effects
done on time my my visual effects team
was so smart and that they hired
multiple houses big houses to all start
work at the same time which you usually
don't really do you usually rely heavily
on a single house a single visual
effects house so that process for us I
think was only like four months you know
typically it's gonna be more like six or
seven months there is a deadline that is
not fungible right like it's yeah
staring ideas oh yeah and yeah I mean
movies this size you know work from
their release dates backwards you start
the process reverse engineering from the
day the movie's going to come out are
you fiddling with it right up to the
last second the film yeah let me put it
this way my final work on Doctor Strange
was at around 12:30 or 1:00 in the
morning when I finished color timing
which is the last thing you do you
finished the actual color timing of the
master print so that when when you watch
it when you watch the finished color
timing version that's the finished movie
the sound is all mixed you've done all
the work there was to do
it you're finished that's it I finished
that at 12:30 at night and was on a
plane at 6:00 that morning so five and a
half hours later I was on a plane to
Hong Kong to start the press junket so
yes I go I was literally is it on Drive
I mean hey where was this movie yeah
well they would this was all you know on
the Disney lot and you know it's all it
was all in those in those studios and
and we really did
that's unusual you know the the degree
to which we just needed every last
second and that's when I was working
seven days a week in 18-hour days four
months no time for podcasting no time
for podcasting yeah and it's it's it's
exhausting but very exhilarating because
that post process is the most fun it is
it oh yes just editing all
post-production
is so much you all directors believe
that or do different directors I think
that most directors probably prefer
editing to other I think that's probably
them I think the majority of us feel
that way because you get to see all the
work come together it's another phase of
writing you're still getting to write
the movie and it's it's it's as creative
as writing definitely more creative in
my opinion than production but
production is the worst I mean
production is just you know grueling
it's just so good in the sense of like
making sure the craft services gets paid
and stuff for no product production
meaning just working those long hours
and you know and the physical do that
mean what people really don't understand
about making a movie this size is the
physical you know toll that it takes the
physical demand on you is is pretty
extraordinary yeah you know I mean you
you really do enter they people compare
it to war which is the most ridiculous
now yeah yeah we we eat we craft we
catered food and and and sleep in warm
beds every night and we're getting paid
huge amounts of money but and nobody
dies but it's just like war but it is
like it is kind of like joining the army
you know it is it is that kind of boot
camp just brutal this is not for the
faint of heart
no and and you you really do have to
watch what you eat and drink and and and
manage your sleep habits and because if
you don't the moving train that you're
running in front of will mow you over
well that's why I you know I can imagine
personally writing a movie script
someday I can never even imagine
directing a movie it just sounds like so
much stuff is going on it must take a
very special kind of personality to say
like that's what I wouldn't do I want to
be in a thing where there's so many
different failure modes if it could go
wrong the Rowsey yeah and I want to live
with that that is this what you wanted
to do from the start yeah it is for me
it was and I think still is a two-fold
thing you know part of it is just I'm
I'm I have a talent for it I have a
knack for it and I think I I felt that
was going to be the case when I was even
in high school you know just putting
together a little super 8 films and
stuff like that
just felt like I had a knack for
understanding film language and I'd
watched I grew up in a family that
watched so many movies so I understood
movies in a way that I think people my
age typically don't or at least didn't
then I think now it's much more common
you know people are watching so many
films growing up but I think that that
era what I love about directing but the
actual experience of directing is to you
know be do everything in the service of
a piece of artistic entertainment that's
going to be seen by millions of people
and to feel the responsibility of I get
to have a couple hours of their
hard-earned life of their rest time
their hard-earned money is going to be
spent on a Friday night to go with their
girlfriend or wife or family whatever
and watch this movie I want them to have
the best time of their week right you
know and and that that that's always
there and I want them to have something
human and I want them have a human
experience and and and and have fun and
be and be amazed by it and I want them
to remember it and and possibly watch it
again and love it
as a part of their of their life you
know and so you start with that and
that's the goal that's what you're in
service of it's that that's a very
there's a real altruistic I think truth
to that but then in the action of
actually doing it the satisfaction for
me is that it demands usage of every
single thing I'm good at like my ability
to communicate my leadership skills my
salesmanship uh-huh you know along with
my love for film language my
understanding of of cinema history my
ability to write like all is to be able
to utilize and feel like you're in a
profession where you are utilizing
everything that you are really good at
it's all being utilized at the highest
level that's the ultimate job for anyone
yeah it's a building in that sense it's
fulfilling in that sense you know
Flannery O'Connor was asked you know why
do you write these quirky little stories
about freaks these short stories about
freaks and her answer was because I'm
good at it yes that should be already
the answer to why they do what they do
you know because if you're if you're
good at it and you love it that's your
calling that's what you
and you have to do it though within this
framework that we call Hollywood right
like I mean tell tell tell us a little
about your your fitting in with the
whole Hollywood superstructure movies
are up obviously a big part of it but
business is a big part of it yeah those
were a big part of it and so forth
well I think that that I've been
fortunate you know because I've I've
managed to work for various a lot of
difficult people you know and and even
people who are notoriously difficult
with in Hollywood you know I worked for
the Weinsteins for years and and and I
think that I survived a lot of the
people I worked for the past and and
survived in a way a lot of artists
didn't right now and and a lot of good
artists didn't so I think that my
survival skills are strong you know that
there was that but I I thought I think
that it was also my ability to sell my
dad was a car dealer you know and I
didn't yeah my dad owned a couple dark
car dealerships when I was in high
school he law he got sick and lost all
of his money when I was in college but
but I worked as a car salesman for him
and and I've always credited my working
as a car salesman - I think my talents
as a filmmaker is is what it is but I
think that my ability to navigate the
waters of Hollywood and to actually put
together a career and keep working it
has so much to do with my ability to
sell because you're always selling an
idea you're selling a script a pitch
you're selling yourself to your crew
members you're selling yourself to the
studio's to get jobs you're selling
yourself you know in marketing the movie
I mean it's that's such a big part of
the factors to listen to you and you
tell them to do so or short and by the
way so much of that is like so much of
what makes me an effective director was
understanding that as it when in sales
you you know I you come to understand
you can't talk to every customer the
same way your job is to figure out who
are they how do they need to be
communicated with because that's your
job you know and so in this in actors
are the same way they're all powerfully
emotional people but they all need to be
spoken to in different ways depending on
who they are and so you have to learn to
do that and and I think that that I
think so much of
of Hollywood success you know demands
either incredible luck just you know
unparalleled raw genius or an ability to
sell right yeah you're doing those three
yeah helpful yeah two if you have two of
those three then then you know then
you're in really good shape then you're
Stanley Kubrick yeah that's right so you
have done the big blockbuster superhero
thing actually before I leave that topic
how hard is it to keep the humanity the
character narrative strength in a movie
that is just that big I'm really vague
I'm really glad that you asked that
question because I I think that it is
the greatest challenge of directing a
film epic and I think that it's the
number one reason why you see big
Hollywood blockbuster movies that don't
work because a lot of times they've
worked in a script phase in a way that
they don't work by the time they reach
the screen and so often what I can feel
from those movies is that the director
you know was not able some for whatever
reason maybe it was his fault maybe not
or her fault but the that for some
reason that human emotional story was
not was not remaining central during the
production because the production was so
demanding and that in making dr. strange
I was determined that would not be the
way that movie would fail right if there
were plenty of ways for it to fail but I
was like it won't feel it felt that way
so you and what you have what I
literally had to do was I created a
document for every shooting day that
just had for every shooting day that I
was on the movie that had the central
emotional narrative story points for
this character because I knew that that
when I when I was shooting it that that
all of my time would be spent talking to
people about about practical issues and
where the camera goes and and and and
how we can get this done in time and all
of that and it's so easy to lose that
because you don't have time to be
working through that much on a movie of
the size and so every day I would go in
and I would remind myself
what is the I would start by reading at
the top of my script what I just pitched
you it's a psychotropic whatever it was
psychotropic ma you know mind trip
action movie about one man overcoming
himself just to remind myself I'm that's
what I'm making yes and and then to
really focus on that with the characters
and and really understand here's the
emotional quality of what this guy and
the people around him are going through
and and I never lost sight of that while
making Doctor Strange and and the reason
why that's so important is people paid
to go see these movies because they see
the trailer and they see the spectacle
and they love Marvel whatever but when
they get in there it the reason it works
is because of an emotional connection to
those actors yeah it's always the
ceiling for how good a movie can be a
movie cannot be better than your lead
characters story and performance can't
it's impossible doesn't matter how great
everything else is if your lead actors
character and performance are not
emotionally satisfying the movies not
good if they if it if that is satisfying
it's amazing how many things can be can
not work and the movie will still work
for you and that's the way you push like
the release date to get Benedict
Cumberbatch a movie precisely
you know because because he he just had
a quality that I felt for this
particular character that he would be
able to cover the range of emotions and
the cockiness and the arrogance and and
still maintain likability because he is
such a prick in the beginning of the
movie as he was in the comics you know
and he being Stephen strange not but
yeah no no he being Stephen strange
Benedict is lovely I love him he's
really genuinely a great a great guy but
yeah so you got to get the right actors
and those roles and you've got to stay
focused on that you know and now you
think of yourself as mostly a
storyteller is that your task or is it
something broader than that I I think
that I think it's broader than that
because I think cinema is broader than
that
you know I do I I do think that a story
itself is important because the story
says something that only a story can
okay it can't what is what makes a good
story
a good story is that it can't be reduced
to something else it can only what it
what it is communicating can only be
communicated through that story so you
have to be a good storyteller but I
think that's you know for me and this is
how I feel about movies i watch as well
as the movies I make cinema is something
broader than just that it's a major
component perhaps it's even the spinal
column of the animal of a movie but the
flesh and blood of cinema is something
to me that is more artful and ineffable
that there's a quality to a dreamlike
quality to the cinema experience of
submitting yourself to the immersion in
this alternate reality that that that
supersedes you know the individual that
supersedes the art forms of just music
and and photography and blocking like
theater and the storytelling of
literature because it is a combination
of all those things and the end result
is still greater than the sum of its
parts are you a fan of live theatre also
not really you know and I think that
I've sensed that but ya know I really I
really I'm really very hard on theater
you know because I I find the experience
so so limiting compared to cinema I
would much rather watch you know I'd
rather watch a mediocre movie than a
good play but a great play or you know
can certainly be an experience that's
unlike anything else when I saw Hamilton
you know for example it's like well this
is one of the great it's works of art in
the of the last hundred years you know
and and I experienced it and understood
why but but I think that cinema is is a
kind of experience that is as close to
dreamlike magic that we get when it
comes to art and entertainment you know
I think that they're different I mean I
was just in London a couple weeks ago
and we got to see Ian McKellen as King
Lear at the Duke of your idea right and
so it was an interesting experience not
only because he's fantastic but because
you're familiar
with him from movies right and now he's
20 feet away from you being King Lear
and there's things that obviously a live
theater performance can cannot do that
cinema can but I think vice versa also
right and I think that uh maybe
comparing them is wrong I just thought
of it because you were talking about the
history a little bit and I think of
cinemas coming out of live theater back
in the day for sure but it's you know
it's at a hundred some years to develop
and it's it's it's able to do things now
that live theater can't even imagine
yeah and I think that that the theater
that I do enjoy tends to be you know
more minimalistic I will always enjoy a
good Shakespeare play because because
it's some of the greatest writing in
human history and and if it's if it's
well made and well acted that's going to
be an extraordinary experience no matter
what so what I don't like is a spectacle
theater yeah and part it's one of the
reasons why I liked Hamilton because I
loved I loved just entering in and
seeing oh this is just an empty stage
and it was a pretty pretty simple
backdrop and the experience was the
music the movement you know these things
that are inherently theatrical when it
came to you know I mean people I'm gonna
step on toes but it's like you know see
the big phantom you know chandelier
hovering over the audience I just think
it's ridiculous oh yeah I'm like why you
know I can I can pay eight dollars and
you know at a movie that movie matinee
and see something a thousand times
greater than this you know right now and
they think that gives that that that an
immersive quality of cinema gives it
this particular art form a way to get
and connect with people's emotions and
you have sort of a visceral response
that other methods do I do i do I think
I think that it is primarily emotional I
think that that in it I think that is
holistically emotional I think that
that's maybe it's hard for me to
describe it because I usually don't have
to but there is a soulful holistic
emotional quality to the cinema
experience that I do believe transcends
the the the nature of the experience of
any other individual kind of art and and
in it speaks to our subconscious
in a way that other art forms don't and
especially directors who are aware of
that and can and can utilize that well I
just think that it's the greatest art
form you know and it's the only only
because it's the amalgam of all the
other great art forms it's the amalgam
of photography and and literature and
theatre and and music and and when and
when all those things come together into
something that is pure and creates a
pure experience the the emotional power
of it can be overwhelming you know and
and and for me even a bad movie has a
quality of that that I still prefer to
you know and the closest thing to I
think it's probably music you know in
the way that it can can move you and
transcend your your experience and then
I'm an avid reader so there's no
disrespect for literature or formal art
but and this approach it makes perfect
sense when you say that that one of your
favorite genres would be the horror
movie right yeah that's a kind of
connection you don't see that many
horror plays right it's hard to get
scared in a play because you you need
that the intimacy of of being lost
within your own within your own
imagination and within your own fears
and certainly horror literature works
great you know good or a good scary
Stephen King book scares you you know
but not in the same way that a horror
movie does you know you don't usually
read even a great chapter in the shining
and physically feel your pulse race you
know as you do in a good horror film
where you you get actually really scared
and and and it that's that's what and I
think that cinema can do that you know
this is something this is something I'm
just gonna add in here on the wall we're
on this subject because we're talking
about the nature of movies themselves
and like what are movies and I think one
of the real clues to what makes movies
special is the categorization of movies
because you've got action movies horror
movies dramas comedies thrillers and
then you've got things like
documentaries but science fiction you
what's that rom-coms yeah yeah but those
are yeah that's still still in the
comedy section okay it's a brand branch
out under the comedy banner these major
categories they're the same now on
Netflix as they ever were always wearing
blockbuster and I had this revelation
one day when I was I think a student
film student and I was going into a
blockbuster video somewhere and I was
looking at the now and I just the
thought hit me who created these
categories who created these categories
like this this has this have been the
categories that I've known right movies
to be under my whole life and the more I
thought about it I thought well the
audience created these categories the
audience by by wanting to see these
different kinds of movies that separated
into these like seven or eight major
categories and when I realized that's
what they really are is they're the
major categories of human emotion you
know fear for horror you know comedy for
laughed or joy drama for sorrow for you
know deeper feelings the the visceral
excitements is action anxiety is
thriller you know science and I think
science fiction is always has is always
built upon a sense of wonder of
wonderment combined usually with some
other genre and and I think that that
this is these basic speaking to these
basic human emotions is the nature of
cinema it's just what it does is what
movies do so there's an obvious question
there's like to get your take on why do
people go to horror movies why do we
want to be scared like why would you
actually pay money for someone to make
you feel unpleasant in some sense uh uh
a lot of people don't you know and and I
think that the people who do you know
they like it for the same reason they
like roller coasters is it's the the the
powerful feeling of fear which i think
is arguably the most powerful human
emotion and to feel to to experience the
the visceral power of that emotion in an
environment where you know you're safe
like in a roller coaster you know you're
not going to fly out of the car but you
feel like you're gonna fly out of the
car and and and so you're experiencing
the adrenaline rush of that and then for
people who are serious horror fans and
and people like me who who consider it
you know one of the undervalued great
forms of movie art it's that it gets to
some of the most important human
questions about good and evil about
metaphysics
you know the questions of the afterlife
and and the meaning of existence and and
how how unspoken and unspeakable fears
can be tapped into by great horror like
these are all may these are things that
I love you know I speak by maxing poetic
about it you know because I because I do
it love it I love it and I revere it and
I think it's important but I also
completely understand and have no have
nothing negative to say to some people
who just don't like that and so if
somebody doesn't doesn't like that
experience they don't like it and might
and by the way if they have spent having
spent my entire adult life making horror
films there is no such thing as a horror
type you know it's like you you know
I've met some of the bravest cops in New
York City who are terrified to watch a
horror movie and wouldn't never do it
like guys who drag people out of the
towers on 9/11 yeah you know and and and
if risked their lives over and over
again you know and they're just like
just don't show me any of that stuff you
know and then and I'll meet a little old
lady in a flower shop who's you know
seen every Nightmare on Elm Street movie
something human well it's hard to
predict yeah it is very hard yeah but I
want it I do want to get into these
metaphysical presuppositions I mean I
think for you questions of evil and
purpose and meaning in life come into
why you do hard but maybe also why you
do other movies also it's it's why and
we disagree about the my difficult we do
we have it's one of the things that he
does agreement that's okay it's one of
the things I've loved about our
relationship is that we've we've spoken
about this many times you know we have
very differing views of the nature of
existence itself you know but but we've
always admired and appreciated the other
person's point of view and and and
respect you know the fact that both of
those views are very personal and
powerful to us as individuals
you know they inform everything else
that we do in our work and the way we
think about everything from you know
practical life politics right down to
the meaning of art of our of our own
life and for me it I do think that
everything that I've done
perhaps the through line in all the work
that I've done including all the script
work on things that have not um you know
been produced is a combination of this
sort of love for genre you know for
horror thriller action type sci-fi
movies and some kind of cross over into
metaphysical questions you know
questions about the nature of human
existence and and possibilities of what
life could be and certainly the moral
questions that arise is that's what -
one of the interesting things to me
about horror is it's almost it's very
difficult to make an amoral horror film
you know or a non moral you know horror
it was going to be immoral one way or
the other you're the movie even if it
seems to have no moral center that
becomes a moral point well good and evil
are out there good evil and so once you
were dealing in horror you're you're
landing in terrain that is inherently so
philosophical
it's inescapable and I think it's
inescapable in a way that it's not in
other genres and and so I think that was
it was a big part of the pull to that
and the fact that that there's a lot of
room to improve the genre and has been
in my life and I've really watched it
happen and watching it happen you know
there's a it was more sophistication now
I think that that horror in the in the
in the 80s in the 70s and 80s was just
slasher movies like all anybody ever
thought about you know but but with the
exception of master works by great non
horror directors like Kubrick making The
Shining or freaking making The Exorcist
or something like that but but I think
that now it's a genre that has gained a
lot of respect for for how it comments
on the human experience yeah I mean I
remember being I love sinister and I
thought is extremely scary and I'm not
an aficionado by any means but since
then the babadook is yeah amazingly good
movie and just now we started watching
the hunting of Hill House which we were
just talking about that on the way here
because we saw we saw people well and by
the way I we saw that of the billboard
and I asked Cargill I said have you
heard anything he said I hear it's very
good and it's Mike Flanagan I tweeted
about the release of that yesterday and
I haven't seen it yet
but he is such a good director so good
and he is so talented and of course the
I've read the book the Shirley Jackson
novel is is amazing and really scary
yeah
and which goes back to the original
haunting by Robert Wise which was you
know a great movie and and it's uh you
know I these these kind of tales
regardless of your you know cosmological
view of you know and regardless of your
philosophical presuppositions about
about the existence of the immaterial
world or the existence of anything not
Material these movies speak to to our
fears they just do it like that and in
other movies you've made there's there's
obviously a supernatural element but the
response of the human characters to what
they're seeing is what it would be right
or right that's what counts like I like
I would totally feel this way in this
circumstance which I don't believe will
ever happen because I'm an atheist but
yeah that's how I would feel that's what
matters right oh yeah and it's funny
because I think that even if even if
you're right and I'm wrong about the
nature of the universe the likelihood of
something coming along you know in the
course of history that is that that
undoes all of our safe assumptions about
the nature of the world is going to be
frightening that would like that
encountering that will be scary exactly
you know and I think and I think it's I
think one of my favorite things that you
I remember hearing you talk about is how
you know these sort of big revelations
and science are typically non-intuitive
yeah and and you know relativity I mean
what could be more non intuitive than
relativity you know and it takes so much
effort just to try to conceptualize and
understand what that it what that he
even is and the fact that somebody
figured it out to me is still incredible
I still don't understand how that and
honestly quantum mechanics is a hundred
times worse the the opening line of my
new book is going to hope is right now
something like you don't need a PhD in
theoretical physics to be afraid of
quantum mechanics but it doesn't hurt oh
that's great and and and I think I just
think that that it all gets back to the
mystery of the unknown and I think that
that's something where you and I have
always had a an unspoken overlapping
respect which is there's there's a lot
that we know but there's there's so much
that we don't know you know and there's
so much that that's still out there to
surprise us yeah and and that's so much
of the human experience not just in when
it comes to knowledge and you know what
we what we know and what we believe
about the universe but that's our day to
day experience life surprises us and it
scares us and it does that throws us
these curveballs you know and and I
think that this particular realm of
visual storytelling is a great way to
reckon with those fears and you've made
a couple movies about exorcisms yeah and
correct me if I'm wrong but you think
that this is a real thing right that
means that there is possible that's it
well here's the intersection yeah it's
funny because I didn't expect you to
bring that up but and now that you have
I'm really glad you did because what I
what I can say about it is again the
primary word I would use to describe my
own feeling about the phenomenon is
mystery there's a great mystery to it
but possession and exorcism is a fact
it's a it's an anthropological reality
that exists in all cultures and always
have people get into these crazy
mindsets you know and and start doing
these things with certain predictable
patterns and then there's this kind of
shock therapy ritual that every culture
has developed that is often very
effective you know and so for me that's
the starting point the starting point of
what makes it so interesting isn't
theological it's anther
logical right you know that this is a
part of this is something that happens
and in fact no one can deny that in the
real world exorcists go to people's
houses because they believe that they
are possessed and things happen
precisely and I think that and I think
that if you know and I've read dozens of
books on the subject including very
skeptical books and I think I think at
the very least you have to if you look
at credible cases when when I say
credible I mean well researched you know
well analyzed cases and certainly when
you look at it as a phenomenon globally
and historically I do think there is a
trance state quality of it in in in in
the more extreme cases of what I would
what I would call it a legitimate case
is at the very least that right and and
and there in you are entering into
something very mysterious about the
human mind at the very least you know
and and so I I found that compelling and
when I first made the Exorcism of Emily
Rose I have a an open and liberal enough
view of of Scripture for example you
know and and my own theological views of
things and I'm always challenging myself
to question what I what I believe one of
the reasons I went into that was to see
if do I do I believe that there's
anything behind this and do I believe
that the devil exists is that's just all
just a construct you know and in that
particular case what was so fascinating
was by the time it was over I didn't
have any more answers than I went into
going in because there really didn't
seem to be any simple way to explain
what happened to that particular girl
right in that case like no matter what
angle I looked at it from it was just
confounding and that's why it was
sparked sparked so much interesting
conversation but I but I I will finish
by saying that I think that the vast
majority of what you see in here out
there people you know attributing to
being demon possession and and the other
work of the devil is nonsense
you know it's like it's and the vast
majority of it is is is absolutely
ridiculous you know and and and in the
more extreme cases you know I could be
wrong maybe maybe it's all some kind of
psychological trance State
no but but I personally do I believe
that there's a spiritual component
behind it I do yeah and you know there's
no question well there's very little
question I guess there's always some
question but it seems to be useful in
describing human actions to believe in
the existence of evil some things just
are evil yeah and how and there's a lot
of evil going on in your films
how would your films be different if
tomorrow you became a naturalist oh
that's a really good question um they I
you know it's a really really really
good question I like the question a lot
I mean it would be completely different
because they would be made from a
completely different human experience
you know my my spirituality
you know if I'm honest has been you know
certainly scrutinized intellectually I
certainly take philosophy very seriously
I've changed a lot of what I believe
because of critical thinking and and and
all of that but if I'm honest my my core
belief system cut is born of my
experience I wasn't raised in a
religious home but it was has always
been my nature from the time I was a
small child to look around and and feel
the world as something that is much more
than the material in front of me I've
always felt that the world was that what
was real was more than this and maybe
what was primary was was more than this
you know have something else not even
more but just something else that that
I've always experienced the world more
in materially than I have materially and
that's just my been my my way of
experiencing it and so so I connect that
that part of myself that experiences the
world in that mystical kind of way I
late to cinema in as a part of that I
relate to the felt of film experience as
well as a viewer and as as an artist is
very very connected to that so I think
that and when it comes to philosophy you
know where you would land you know much
more with Hume I'll and much more with
crazy Conte
you know and
and sorry that's the deal break yes I
but you know I'm right with him when he
says there's two things I'm sure about
the stars above me and the moral law
within yeah and so I think that that I
think that I do think that that belief
in a moral law pre-existing within human
behavior or something I do believe in
but if I were to become a naturalist and
undo even that I don't
III feel like suddenly this like when
you asked me that question
the honest answer is well you I couldn't
make any of the movies that I've made at
all I wiped the slate clean and and what
would I make I'd have to live in another
life you know and in an effect and if
that actually and by the way it's
possible that something could happen
that would make me able to think that
way and and what would the result be I
think that all I could make movies about
if that happened to me at this point my
life all I could make movies about art
what is that about about the shock value
of experiencing life for so long is in
so powerfully for five decades and then
to suddenly have the rug pulled out from
under you
that's perfectly fair and vice versa I
like to sum up I had a conversion
experience tomorrow oh my god what are
you gonna do not be able to write about
quantum is the most important thing in
your life and this makes me such a bad
Christian too because I hear you say
that I'm like oh god I hope that doesn't
happen that's a good thing but but it
you know I think that the relationship
with mystery is an interesting thing you
brought it up mystery is crucially
important to all movies yeah the whole
storytelling to human existence etc etc
I was really annoyed by the famous JJ
Abrams mystery box TED talk did you see
yeah I did see it and part of it and
maybe I'm being unfair
but part of it seemed to me to be and
maybe we'll disagree about this that he
was saying that mysteries are better if
are better best only good if you don't
even try to solve them in some sense
right like if you assume that they're
not solvable and keep them as mysteries
and to me mysteries are great because
they can be solved I mean I go through
presuming that of course is a million
questions I don't know the answers to
and I will die before I know all the
answers to them but in principle I could
get them and that's what makes the quest
worthwhile well certainly when you're
talking about the mysteries of of the
material world and the mysteries of
science that's a given you know what we
don't know about dark matter and dark
energy and you know these things that in
gravity these things that science is
still chasing of course we have to
believe that they can be answered that
those mysteries can be insulted and and
just as relativity changed our human
experience of the world the I'm sure
future discoveries and quantum mechanics
is already starting to do that as it
seeps out into popular culture it's
starting to affect the way that we feel
most a lot a lot of times in very sloppy
ways and and stories I know but but I
think that that when you're talking
about mystery the mystery of human
experience and the mystery of say the
mystery of God of the concept of God the
nice tree of meaning to me there's
always a quest to comprehend it you know
there's always a quest to get deeper
underneath it that is the point I don't
believe that that there's power in just
acknowledging oh it's a mystery we'll
never know well if that's the case I
don't need to think about it
I love I remember where I first heard
this but I've repeated it before maybe I
maybe I maybe I said it I know I don't
really don't remember but I certainly
something I think about a lot which is
that to me the concept of mystery is not
the presence of something meaningless
but the presence of more meaning than we
can yet comprehend you know that that
there is an awareness of there's more
here than we can get our experience or
brains or hearts around and and the
whole point of evolving as a species
evolving as an individual is to get
deeper into that mystery start to
understand it you know what's there what
is it what what what is what is it
therefore you know
I think that that the important thing to
me though that is worth protecting and I
didn't particularly agree with JJ's
approach on the mystery box either but
what I do believe with respect to
mystery is that we have to make a
practiced kind of discipline to not
think that we understand more than we do
I think that you know I think that's
really important and I think it's
important because I think and I've said
this many times before but I think both
science and religion you know have been
guilty and continued to be guilty sort
of felt sort of propagating the idea
that we understand a lot more than we
really understand you know and they both
done it in very different ways but
they're broadcasting a sensibility to to
their constituents you know that we got
the world figured out well what are
terrible things by the way that we teach
kids science is that we teaches a set of
facts that we've learned rather than as
a process for making hypotheses and then
testing them against reality that
statement alone is something that people
don't understand yeah people don't think
of science as a process right they don't
it's not that hard they think they think
of as irrevocable fact that's it and
yeah and well then sometimes it is
revoked
oh yeah that's like exactly that's the
whole history of science has been a
process of it of it sort of undercutting
itself as it gets deeper into it it's
understanding of how complex the world
really is all right we can move into the
lightning round because I know that you
have to go to see a hardier house right
yes yeah we're meeting a meeting at
Katsuya and then we're going to we're
gonna go to Warner Brothers horror tour
very consistent yes optical approach so
but then very quickly because I do want
to talk about I mean you're not just a
director but you're a you are a lover of
cinema and the history of cinema yeah I
mean what is your relationship to that
history and what would you recommend to
our listeners out there in podcast land
like you know should they download
Kurosawa and no you know my relationship
too is that you know I first learned you
know movies from my father primarily
because he was a movie lover
but he was strut he was straight genre
you know he'd not not horror either but
he just loved action movies he loves you
know thrillers and so I grew up seeing
tons of movies American movies we see
two three movies a day sometimes in our
family and so I developed a real love
for movies and and and then of course
when when video technology came in I
started to rewatch movies all the time
but then when I got to college I was
exposed to international cinema and and
it was really my discovery of the art of
international cinema that that made me
really want to be a filmmaker and
because I the first time that I saw
Fellini is eight and a half I just
actually had a panic attack at the end
of the movie the density of that
experience the dream quality of that
film was so overwhelming III kind of
panicked I had literally left the
classroom because I couldn't I couldn't
an experienced it I couldn't understand
what was happening to me into my brain
in this experience and and and then as I
continued to rewatch it the you know the
layers of meaning and poetry and that in
that movie were so amazing and I didn't
know movies can do this you know and so
that sent me really down the rabbit hole
of exploring all the major movements in
world cinema you know going starting
when the silent era in American cinema
you know and going all the way through
the various major movements to him and
it was it was primarily Japanese cinema
and European art cinema that you know
the fresh new wave and Italian
Neorealism
these things really spoke to me and
Kurosawa is a great point for people who
are have limited exposure to
international cinema Kursaal was a great
starting point because he took I think
the sensibility of Hollywood movies the
entertainment value of Hollywood movies
and merged it with the artfulness
of European movies of his time he was as
much a fan of John Ford as he was a big
Marburg man you know and so there's a
quality to his movies that are high art
and high entertainment at the same time
that you really don't get with many
directors ever and and so he's a great
starting point you know watch watch the
use google the 10 best
I saw movies and every one of them will
be a masterpiece worth what worth
watching but you also have to find the
directors that you love you know it's
like Shawn you know guitars on guitar is
not for everybody but for those of us
who like loved those movies or Bergman
like a Bergman movies you you know you
and I is so interesting like I would
love to watch a Bergman film with you
because he really believed in the
godless universe he believed in in and
no God or if there is a God it is
certainly silent it's certainly
non-communicative we are alone you know
and and even though I've never held that
view I experienced his experience of the
world through those movies so powerfully
and this is what movies can do I think
again in ways that other art forms don't
is they can well other art forms do the
same thing but for me movies do it in a
way nothing else does I feel that
experience I feel his human experience
through those movies and and I am made
more human for having felt it and for
having understood it and having related
to the truth quality in it because even
though I have a system of belief that is
different than that I know what it's
like to feel alone in the world I know
what it's like to not feel safe in in in
in the world and I know certainly what
it's like to be wracked with doubt which
a lot of his films were and I think
that's something that we both agree and
then probably Bergman would agree with
us is that the question of whether or
not God exists matters it's probably
exactly nothing I think that's exactly
right and I think that that you know we
live in an age now of just you know
shouting people are very shouting at
each other and and you know one of the
things I love is being able to have
conversations like this and and and
here's something like that from somebody
like you that that question is an
important question it's a profound
question it's it's one of the essential
questions and and it needs to be
reckoned with you know and and that's
more important than to me hearing that
is a much more important voice than
anybody advocating why they believe what
they believe you know the starting point
is we all need to deal with certain
realities of we have to answer certain
questions if we are to live a full full
life an enlightened life we should we
should be we should have an
understanding of what we think the human
experience really is okay two more
questions the lightning round for
whatever reason you're told that you can
make one more movie ever in your life
what would it be
hmm you're allowed to change your mind
later but well it would be the next
movie that I'm going to make but I can't
say anything about it that's the correct
answer we've made everybody happy you're
gonna make a move good yeah no and it's
true living the life you know and I do
believe in it because I made I made one
decision early in my career you know to
take a big studio movie because that's
what you do you know when you're a young
filmmaker if you get the opportunity you
take it and and I ended up regretting
that decision and and since then I've
always operated under the belief that I
should make every movie as though it's
my last movie because one day it will be
exactly right now and you know you never
know when that's gonna go down the
afterlife I presume the director for
users and now writers and directors
directors go to Limbo riders go to
heaven that's all right the last one is
you are out there on Twitter
yeah I've seen people off saying things
I mean you don't try to piss people off
I think that's your goal but you're
happy to say things truthfully honestly
right and and I'm on Twitter yeah also
we're people always debate you know it's
not Twitter in particular but just
should we all just shut up right like
should we protect ourselves should we
lower the noise level and just not talk
but I find it very stimulating you know
I try to put people my Twitter feed who
are rewarding yeah people who talk about
Twitter is just a you know a source of
terrible things I'm like you get to
choose who you follow yeah
so what is your relationship with that
sort of more social aspect I mean I I
you know I
I left Twitter for a couple months just
to to feel the Noize kind of calm down
and and and to reevaluate my belief in
it and I came back and I came back
because I do value it I do find it to be
rewarding both you know by controlling
my Twitter feed and who it is that I'm
actually going to listen to and and and
and having the lists of people who I in
a particular mood well I want I want to
I want to see what this list has the
same times I just want to hear about the
NBA right right exactly but I but I
think as a user you know it's certainly
been enlivening in that I've met a lot
of great people as a result of it you
know made a lot of good connections but
I love it as as a as a form of
expression I'm you know I'm not out
there to try to influence anybody or
change anybody's mind about anything you
know so I'm not trying to I don't want
to shout into the void about you know
what I'm angry about and and ice tweeted
plenty about Trump but usually just
because it's an expression of this is
how I am feeling today about this
lunatic
yeah and and and I also want scaling
back on that I'm trying to do less and
less of that but I love it as as just an
opportunity to you know to express you
know what I think and feel about things
and for me it's usually cinema and a
little bit with politics but cargo and I
spoke about this last night and cargo
has been actively using his Twitter feed
to tweet specifically about writing
about the craft of writing and he was
saying to because I said to him last
night I said what do you think I should
be doing differently with my feet you
know because I am getting a little bored
with with the whole world of it and he
was encouraging me to tweet more about
the craft of directing yeah and I
thought you know that's really true
because no one's doing that yeah and and
I can do that and I think that that
would help will have value and I think
I'll enjoy it and I love teaching you
know and that's something of where I can
actually give valuable information that
very few people have and nobody on
Twitter is really doing that well it
makes perfect sense maybe but it seems
like there's a vibrant screenwriting
Twitter in a way there's not a vibrant
director absolutely true yeah absolutely
true I think I think
and I think that's unfortunate I think
it you know it should be that way I
think there should be a better if I can
chime in for a second yes see Robert
Cargill did you take a medium in which
you're supposed to write and then you
put writers in it and what do you expect
what I mean married to a journalist they
stopped on Twitter yes scientists are
much more reluctant but all right that
all makes a lot of sense this is
extraordinarily fun and insightful so
scott derrickson thanks so much thank
you
[Music]